A picture is worth 1,000 words and
images play an integral
part of every website.
The HTTP archive has it pegged
at near 1.2 megabytes per page,
which means images take
up 65% of every website.
In order to do responsive web design,
we need to consider images.
If the rest of my page is changing
based on device characteristics.
Wouldn't it make sense that my
images should be changing too?
>> You're absolutely right, Cam.
Using the same image, but
changing the resolution is probably
one of the most common use cases.
Think providing a standard image for
a laptop, but a 2X image for
a high DPI display, like
a Chromebook Pixel, or a Retina iMac.
The best way to do this is using the
source set attribute on an image tag.
With source set, the browser will
choose which file it wants, and
then only download that one.
>> Well that might work for
logos and some other things, but
what about the case where I want
a different crop of an image?
It doesn't make sense to show a big,
wide image on a narrow portrait phone.
>> Exactly, and
that's what's called art direction, and
where the new picture element come in.
The picture element uses media
queries to select which image to use,
but responsive images could
be a course of their own.
Thankfully my good friend and
fellow developer advocate
Sam Dutton has you covered here.
Hey, Sam.
>> Thanks Pete, great stuff.
When you're finished with this course,
you'd like to find out more about
responsive images, stuff like
the picture element source set, come and
check out our course
on responsive images.
>> Thanks, Sam.
>> So Pete, it seems like we've
covered all the usual elements for
responsive design, what about tables?
>> That's a great question.
Let's take a look.
>> Cool.